foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
tonight up here is working on sense of
Britain's economy is in the gutter even
Russia will grow faster than us this
year three years on today from brexit
it's that dream turning into a nightmare
or debate
plus the top US general criticizes the
British army amid dire warnings of an
ammunition shortage and a nuclear
submarine fixed with super glue so is
Britain still a top military power we'll
hear from our defense secretary and one
of our great generals
as Donald Trump vows to ban schools and
teaching children about gender ideology
is a landmark court case brings up
ferocious debate to Britain so how young
is too young for children to learn about
things like gender and sex
live from London this is Piers Morgan
uncensored well good evening New London
welcome to Piers Morgan understands that
nothing in living memory has done more
to divide this country and Define our
politics than brexit I didn't support it
but frankly I do understand why 17 and a
half million people did it wasn't as the
critics said about bigotry racism or
hate in the most part it was about
rolling the dice and striving for
something better as they saw it for our
freedom and Independence project fear
warned the British people their lives in
their country would collapse if they
dared to gamble on the unknown and
that's with Donald Trump in the U.S many
people answered back by saying the
status quo wasn't good enough anyway the
people promising the apocalypse the same
people who promised to make our lives
infinitely better for years and failed
but exactly three years on it's time for
some cold hard truths the promises made
Pro breaks it have also been broken
debate is about democracy
is it no time we took back control of
our immigration policy Take Back Control
of the 350 million pounds
of the European Union every week
the Free Trade Agreement should be one
of the easiest in human history the UK
has voted to leave the European Union
[Applause]
23rd go down in our history as our
independence day
brexit means brexit and we're going to
make a success of it we've got an oven
ready deal put it in the microwave
[Music]
turn that microwave on
today the IMF said that the UK economy
will shrink this year will be worse off
than any other significant economy
including Russia think about that a
nation pounded by sanctions locked out
of the global banking system cast aside
as the world's Pariah will grow faster
than we will in the UK Britain's the
only G7 economy that will actually
shrink this year that's the forecast the
U.S Canada France Germany Italy Japan
they all had covered lockdowns they're
all battling the same cost living crisis
caused by Putin's War so why are we
worse off or Bloomberg said today that
brexit's custom UK economy 100 billion
pounds a year the economy is four
percent smaller than it would have been
but it never happened they say
so where are the benefits that's my big
question vote Lee promised 350 million
pounds a week for the NHS the NHS is on
its knees brexitier said We Take Back
Control of our borders well that's not
happening immigration is rising the
borders are in chaos many Industries are
short of workers ask anyone in
hospitality
they said we'd strike lucrative trade
deals across the world not least with
the us we haven't have we disarray of
Northern Ireland anger in Scotland are
testing the very existence of the United
Kingdom Brett and frankly feels like a
bit of a basket case lurching from
shambles to chaos maybe that's why a
staggering new poll published by unheard
shows a 647 of the 650 UK constituencies
now I think brexit was a mistake
having voted to remain I backed brexit
in the end because I believe in
democracy and the will of the people I
didn't back the principle of it I just
backed the principle of you give the
people of the country what they voted
for and the majority voted to leave the
European European Union but the will of
the people may now be changing well
joining me now clinical journalist Avis
and Tina talk TV presenter Richard Tice
lawyer and activist Gina Miller who took
the government to call over the brexit
process one twice and the founder of the
black farmer and brexit Backer a Wilfred
Emanuel Jones so welcome to all of you
Richard Tice
here's my problem with brexit I wanted
it to work didn't vote for it wasn't
completely sure I'm honest it was a
complex debate uh understood a bit of
both sides but in the endbody remain
once I knew my my side had lost I voted
for democracy I voted actually for Boris
Johnson's conservative party because
they were the only party in that
election that said they would honor the
result of the referendum I thought that
was more important than anything else
but as we sit here three years on from
actually coming into into fruition I'm
really struggling to see any of the
benefits that we were promised and in
fact all I'm seeing is the opposite it's
become a millstone around this country
right great intro lovely look the first
major benefit am I wrong no you're
completely wrong
um but the first major benefit was the
vaccine rollout literally brexit save
lives because we ordered the vaccines
it's the truth Gina you know it no other
EU classes
no other EU country okay wait a minute
okay wait a minute here's what we're
gonna do let Richard say what he thinks
happened okay on the vaccine on the
vaccine okay and you can immediately
respond and by the way I do know what
happened to be very interesting how this
plays out Richard so on the vaccines we
were able to order the vaccines early
because we made the decision not to join
the eu's own vaccine acquisition whereas
some of the other countries like Germany
like the Netherlands they wanted to
order their own vaccines and they were
stopped by Brussels that's what happens
that's not true for three reasons one is
we were in the transition period so we
were still under EU law
secondly no country not even us or
existing members had to join the joint
scheme that was not part of the of the
agreement the reason they did was not
for sovereignty and wonders not for law
the EU countries decided for Technical
and medical reasons not to actually
jointly roll out vaccines and not to go
the route we did it had nothing to do
with sovereignty and it had nothing to
do with law it had nothing to do I'm
sorry it's the truth we were under EU
law at the time we were in the
transition who ended up with the fastest
vaccine the UK did it save lives brexit
slaves the reality no no no
but that was not because of brexit
that's the LIE isn't it 27 they all had
their own uh Acquisitions
no but just the fact is we didn't need
to be in the EU we could have done
exactly the same way we wouldn't have
done none of the other countries the
problem with the brexit discussion is
that your your argument is steeped in
ideology and it steeped in an ideology
that harks back from 19 50 and the
problem with 1950 is that we had the
Empire and we were able to pillage other
countries and we were able we were able
to take labor in from other countries
nowadays but nowadays we have to go and
entice people to come and work here and
our services do not function if we can't
bring people in what about getting our
own what about getting our own people to
work we've got five million people I
hate that it's such a silly argument
it's not it's absolutely look after your
own people who's going to train people
to work in the NHS right now right now
when we can't afford vacancies well
there is nothing by the way there is not
a restaurant owner in the country who
won't tell you that brings has been a
disaster but for recruiting stuff is
we've just had record lawful immigration
of over a million people last year we
haven't got a People shortage we've got
a willing worker shortage because we
have truly highly taxed in this country
well the toys have utterly failed to do
if you're going to do a job do it give
me two other benefits of brexit we
should have cut taxes no give me two
other benefits do all the benefits of
having they haven't done this
you can't on the one hand say that my
monologue was very eloquent but
completely wrong when I say where are
the benefits of brexit and then when I
pin you to the ground and say well what
are these benefits you say well they
haven't happened yet because they
haven't taken advantage of it so I'm
right then I'm not wrong I'm right look
the point there have been no discernible
benefits so far but the opportunity
wrong what I said was I'm actually
completely right the point is that
because you've been like that picture of
prince Andrew in the bar for telling you
to prove that he couldn't have gone up
to anything in the bath all that did was
prove the opposite but you're then
saying after three years therefore that
means we should stop and we should no no
you should do no nobody here's what I'm
asking here's what I'm asking and you
know what I want you to come in here
here's what I'm asking at what point if
we do not see discernible benefits and
we see a lot of negatives of negatives
well a lot of negatives and Gina will
explain them in a moment but at what
point do we as a country if it looks
more and more like an act of self-harm
do we at the very least consider going
back to the country and asking the
country what they think because if that
unheard map looks right then that looks
like a lot of people are having buyer's
remorse no I don't agree with you on
that I think that it was so destructive
where we are at the moment is that we
have to limit the damages being done
because the idea of some people say that
we could actually it will get better in
10 15 20 whenever it is years that's not
going to help people now who are
suffering that's not going to help
people who are using food banks no no
second referendum no no second reference
but all the tools period right none not
what we need to do is fix the deal we
have and actually forget about single
Market going back in renegotiating any
other deal everything we have to do is
already in the existing agreements that
we signed both sides signed up to the
trade and Corporation agreement and the
Northern Ireland protocol both of those
bills are those acts and treaties and
Agreements are international
actually have Clauses in them that could
fix the things that are not working but
the problem is there's no political will
on any party at the moment to go back
because all the Clauses are there okay
let me all right you've just published
an opinion from two of the leading
lawyers in the EU called addressing
brexit problems it's on our true and
fair Party website it says exactly the
Clauses and how you can fix it okay so
your your is your view then that brexit
could work if they fix all the Clauses
now what I'm saying is we have to go
sector by sector around the country do
you think it could still work brexit we
have no choice oh we have a choice
what's the choice well listen we had a
choice because in a space of 40 years we
made one choice and then made the
opposite Choice yeah you're not going to
let us back in and it takes about 14
years ask you well actually I must I'm
not so sure all right let me bring it I
want to bring in the man who hasn't
spoken yet been waiting very patiently
so Wilfred Emanuel Jones the black
farmer from Chippenham you'll be
listening to this Wilfred you were I
think you voted brexit you've been a
strong supporter of it yeah but how are
you feeling today three years on from it
coming into play uh we're given all the
negative Vibes about brexit now
Paul Richard has been being gave in a
bit of a kicking but I just think looks
no he doesn't know he doesn't deserve it
because I think what everybody's
forgetting any change involves pain
those of us who were brexiteers we
cannot stand here and says actually we
are now at this particular moment seeing
the benefit it does not mean that in
another five ten years we will then see
the benefits is there anything is going
to actually determine some having some
faith that the decision we made three
years ago will pay off for sometimes the
reasons
sometimes the strongest thing a country
can do or leaders can do is just admit
when they got something wrong we don't
they don't have to be demonized for it
my question really is peers this clock
is it open-ended does it go on forever
if in 10 years time brexit has been a
demonstrable disaster do we do we just
carry on peers let me talk yes well Fred
what I'm saying is that it's unfair it's
unfair to judge people three years in I
think we were having this conversation
in five ten years time oh yes really
because we don't really have the freedom
yet that we actually voted for if we
cannot even sort out the uh the
immigration
we've actually had I would say about
eight years right because we had a year
before the referendum to get our ducks
in a row about what brexit would look
like the referendum happened in 2016.
it's now 2023. it's not three years is
it it's eight years yes
we sit here nothing's working even
Richard died
[Music]
of the energy crisis is because of the
inflation right that's not nothing to do
that is
you know that I actually don't confuse
me I will not be disingenuous and say I
don't think they're all contributive
factors it's one but I also know that
there are specific issues about exit
which people will tell me who run
restaurants and bars and all these
things they all say that brexit has been
a massive problem for them with staff
all of them say the same thing there's
two other things that brexit has done
one is it has caused a labor shortage
yes we might get to somewhere record
immigration last year labor shortage
it's a willing workership
we've had more than a million people
it's the highest immigration I know that
right you've just agreed with me no I
haven't quite a bit agreement I haven't
agreed with you on that what I've said
is they're not the people we need who
are the people so the people have come
into the country they are the people who
left who not picking food who are not
working the Care Service who've left the
NHS we have who are not in Hospitality
every area is suffering but the thing
that I get so upset about in all of this
is that Wilfred says you know five ten
years what about the businesses that are
going to go on in that time right what
about the people who are going to die
because there's nobody to care for them
in the community what about the children
who have no teeth features this we can't
wait to fix these things
that's not a bad idea but it's a great
idea look after the British people is
there a moment is there a moment for you
where if it demonstrably has not worked
you would say okay it hasn't worked no
because or is it just never ending let
me repeat what I just said peers the
challenges the country is facing in
terms of high energy prices
High Cost Of You has got nothing
whatsoever to do with brexit you are
deliberately conflating and confusing
the two to suit your own
arguments I would argue those IMF
numbers today
the worst forecast okay but if you take
the numbers at face value today what
they show is that we are underperforming
a number of other senior countries in
the G7 who all face the same challenges
all Faith covid all faced a war in
Ukraine the common theme for them is
that none of them had the additional
problem of brexit which may explain why
we are currently bottom of the class yes
degrees Yeah I just think it's obvious
isn't it if you don't have trading links
where you suddenly we have got trading
links we've got a trade deal we've got
where's the American Trade Center we
haven't got an emergency we're nowhere
near it hang on appears who we've got
the biggest trading Surplus with the
United States right right
carrots
it's our biggest Surplus it's our
biggest single trading partner still I
mean have you read about our trading
center yes wow and we've got a big
trading Surplus with them which we have
to pay for businesses
have increased by 16 since the end of
the transition period Ramona's and
remainers don't like to talk
to help anybody it's the truth I mean
specifically no we haven't we've Wilfred
are there any Farmers that you've come
across who genuinely believe brexit has
been brilliant for their business
at the moment most people would tell you
that brexit has not been good for their
business okay but you don't make
decisions based on how but hold on well
you but but hold on but you do not make
decisions based on the pain that you're
feeling today it's about having faith
that the decision that we made three
years ago in the long term is going to
be a benefit we're already sitting in a
lot longer than three years ago because
that's my point we made a decision in
2016.
it actually only came into reality yeah
but it takes water yeah but we've had
eight years
it's not a three-year thing is it no no
no
you're going back to your thing about
sort of I don't think it's a small
variety the other thing
that brexit is done is that people don't
want to invest in our country because
we're not seen as a stable credible
political system that we can't deal with
crisis and that's why we're not getting
inward investment and that's going to
affect growth and if people had the
fastest trust that's what I'm saying so
I think brexit taxes when we should be
cutting them we should be going for
growth
you've got to cut you've got to do this
right it's one of the reasons that Rishi
sunak is slightly hesitant about that is
that he campaigned on not doing that
against Liz trust she campaigned on
being the Fairy Godmother cutting
everyone's taxes and the whole thing was
because she was going to fund it of
course if you're going to cut taxes and
go for growth you say all right we're
going to fund it got to leave with that
Gina thank you we're losing you I
appreciate it Wilfred thank you we're
losing you fortunately we're keeping
Richard advice who's very fired up this
evening so we'll get him on this and
maybe you're staying around as well next
tonight a top US general warns the
British army is no longer a top level
fighting force is he right should be
said Richard tithes perhaps to any front
line right now we'll debate with the
former head of the British army Lord
Danner next
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
Donald Trump running for president again
wants to ban gender ideology being
taught in schools in this week of South
London primary school was in court
letting the kids participate in a pride
gay parade it's a debate raging here and
in the US how young is too young do we
talk about issues like trans gender
identity and gay sex will debate all
that first a worrying warning from a
senior U.S general this week who claims
the British army isn't fit for purpose
and may not be able to protect the UK
from Russian aggression is he right or
Ava and Richard are still with me I'm
delighted to be joined by the former
head of the British army Lord done it or
done it great to see you uh Happy 2023
it's our first encounter of the new year
a pretty sobering reading this I have to
say as someone who's had family in the
military in recent years myself to see
the British army described in that way
was a bit disconcerting what were your
thoughts
well the anonymous American General
isn't actually far wider than Mark as
Ben Wallace and James Heath his
administrator for the Armed Forces
um have both acknowledged I mean the
fact of the matter is that the Army has
received the lowest priority in terms of
Ministry of defense spending for the
last 10 to 15 years
um huge history of under investment so
therefore it's not surprising that our
capability is not what we would wish it
to be it's a matter of government Choice
it's a matter of Ministry of Defense
Choice and then eventually when push
comes to shove you have to deal with the
consequences but you know if as long as
the position is now being realized there
is a chance for Ben Wallace to argue the
case for greater resources for defense
to try and up the investment as quickly
as possible what did you make of Boris
Johnson saying that Vladimir Putin had
basically threatened him with a missile
um interesting peers
um I've heard Boris say quite a lot of
things over the years
um whether he misheard that on the
telephone call with Vladimir Putin I
don't know
um I mean the fact of the matter is that
um there is an accepted International
Code of Conduct with between
International leaders that they don't
take each other out so um I think we
take that
half seriously on half of the pinch of
salt it was a good Boris line it caught
a good headline and um I think let's
just move on are you suggesting that our
recently dearly beloved departed prime
minister can't be entirely relied upon
when it comes to veracity of his
rhetoric
oh I wouldn't suggest that peers but
what I would say is that um it was quite
colorful it was very Boris and um I'm
sure it was rooted in a grain of truth
but um it may have been slightly uh
over-exemplified to catch the headlines
which it duly did we're now at a crucial
stage in this war in Ukraine
um coming up to the first anniversary
israeloksha our International Editor to
talk to you She interviewed Ben Morris
defense secretary we got this particular
clip to play to you if you just want to
listen to this
sure how seriously do you take the
threat that he might use tactical
nuclear weapons well it is always a
serious threat simply because it is in
Russian Doctrine yeah they have a an
acceptable view that you can have such a
thing as strategic nuclear weapon and a
tactical Nuclear yes and their idea of
attack nuclear weapon can be ten times
the size of Hiroshima
I mean that's again a sobering statement
for the defense secretary to make
um what is the likelihood or possibility
that a cornered Vladimir Putin if he
feels like he is losing this war with
all the dishonor that would then be
heaped on him back home that he might be
tempted to utilize what is still the
biggest nuclear force in the world
well appears let's just put Ben
Wallace's comment into context
um if a tactical nuclear weapon was 10
times the ferocity of Hiroshima and
Unleashed on Ukraine Ukraine would then
join Pluto and Mars somewhere in the
stratosphere I mean that's just not
going to happen if we're talking about
genuine tactical nuclear weapons we're
talking about a nuclear weapon which
could cause destruction and damage over
say a three to five kilometer area now
how could that be employed let's just go
back to last Autumn when the ukrainians
mounted a very successful
counter-offensive around hakith and they
broke through the Russian lines that is
the moment that if you're desperate you
then consider using a tactical Nuclear
but just think about this one for a
moment those four provinces into which
the ukrainians are now counter-attacking
those four provinces were declared by
Putin to be forever Russia so here's the
question why would Putin want to
irradiate for the next 50 years
some territory that he's declared
forever Russia it just doesn't Stack Up
should the ukrainians give one inch of
any of their territory including Crimea
which was seized from them illegally in
2014 and all the latest Geographic grabs
that Hooters made should they cede any
of this in any kind of deal because they
seem very determined not to
no I think the whole thing about this
conflict now is that there is no basis
for a resolution through negotiation as
zielinski's position is quite clear that
every inch every kilometer of Ukrainian
Sovereign territory should be Ukrainian
Putin on the other hand has got to show
something that he has gained out of the
war he's got to gained some part of
Ukrainian territory so their positions
are irreconcilable therefore you have to
come back to the conclusion that the
only way this conflict is going to be
resolved is on the battlefield which is
why it's really important that we have
continued to supply Ukraine not only
with weapons so they don't lose the war
but to give them the chance in a
counter-offensive later this year to win
this one General can they win it
well I don't know what's going to happen
but I would Hazard that from all the
evidence that we're seeing the Russians
having mobilized a lot of additional
soldiers 100 150 000 maybe 200 poorly
trained poorly equipped very poorly LED
and terribly motivated May well launch a
a new offensive on the evidence of all
that we've seen since the 24th of
February that offensive will fail in a
very bloody way with a lot of Russian
families having tragedies on their
doorstep at that point the ukrainians
need to launch a counter-offensive with
the additional weapons that we have
given them and the training we've given
them with their determination to fight
for their own country and they could
strike a number of successive blows
which could break the morale of the
Russian soldier and the backbone of the
Russian army then it's game over for
Putin game over for Russia and we're in
a whole new ball game
finally if Richard sumac is watching
this and I'm sure he will be
um I'm sure he's an avid viewer appears
Morgan uncensored if not he should be
prime minister
um if he is what is your message to him
about our own armed forces and what he
should be doing to bolster them
well think about our own Armed Forces is
notwithstanding what the American
General said rubbishing our army our
army is made up of fantastic people who
are well LED and well motivated but
they've got pretty old and pretty
equipment not across the across the
piece but in many areas
the thing is that the Army has had the
lowest priority in defense spending for
quite some years so two things have got
to happen one or the other are either
priorities in the ministry of Defense
have got to change to up the priority of
the army and allocate more money to the
Army our land forces let's face it
there's a land war going on in Europe
that actually makes the case or
otherwise Ben Wallace has got to argue
the toss with Rishi sunak and Jeremy
Hunt that the defense budget has got to
go up from two percent of GDP to two and
a half that Boris was talking about to
three percent and Liz trust was talking
about but currently it's pinned back to
two percent actually I think it's a very
strong case to say
was a land war in Europe threatening the
security of Europe threatening our
security that actually the defense spend
should go up from two percent to at
least two and a half percent and a fair
amount of that extra spend be sent on
renewing refurbishing
um bringing up to the 21st century our
land Warfare capability I just thought
of another final question actually well
I've got you because I haven't heard you
react yet to the revelations in Prince
Harry's book that he killed 25 Taliban
and wondered if this you obviously knew
Harry quite well and were the head of
the British army at the time this was
all going on what your reaction was to
to him saying that
well Pierce it's a great question and I
thought you probably would ask it but
I'm afraid I'm going to say what I've
said about 50 times other people have
asked me to comment I'm not commenting
on any of the Prince Harry's stuff so
appears um good question we'll ask no
answer from Dana you're showing an
admirable discretion if only young Harry
would do the same Lord darling great to
talk to you
thanks please
great reaction from the pack uh I could
interview General Janet for hours he's
such a smart guy but your reaction to
what he said there so the the the
difficulty is when he thinks that that
Russia May essentially lose on the
battlefield but I can't see Putin
surrendering and this is why I'm so
worried about that we end up in a a
Forever War where he just keeps sending
bombs and shells just flattening the
place more and more in a sort of
long-term Blitzkrieg which is all just
off which is his way right Abram this is
what he's done throughout his tenure
this is how he grinds people down and he
hopes we all get bored and move on yeah
absolutely I mean that was incredibly
sobering listening to that but I think
there's one really important thing that
give hofstad said actually which is that
Putin may not have even invaded Ukraine
and had Europe chaos and so that might
be an argument in fact he said he said
only yesterday he said that he thought
that within five years it's feasible
that both the UK would return to the EU
and Ukraine would also come back in
absolutely it's got nothing to do with
the EU what is all to do with is NATO
it's interesting isn't it Putin hasn't
invaded any of the other eastern states
where NATO where those States join NATO
the only one he invaded was Ukraine not
a member of NATO you have to stand up to
a bullet do you trust him good Putin of
course not it's just just the most
appalling uh dictator that we've seen in
our lifetime
thank you Pat stay with me uh coming up
next how young is two young to learn
about transgender identity and sex is
four so yeah I would say that is too
young not about after the break
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is talk TV
foreign
Valentine's Day advert is Accused a
glamorizing mastectomies should Brands
be activists like this or distinct to
selling handbags we'll debate that later
but first she's being nicknamed
Christian mum Izzy Montague launched the
election in 2019 against her son's
London school over an LGBT pride parade
tomorrow her case goes to court it's the
first case of its kind in the UK she
will claim a pride parade held at the
school promoted gay Lifestyles and
indoctrinated children and her child was
four at the time it's a debate raging on
both sides of the Atlantic in the U.S 78
of parents do not believe sexual
orientation or gender identity should be
taught to young children and now Donald
Trump has of course got involved and
said it's going to be a central part of
his bid to return to the White House
branding gender ideology a cult
we're going to stop the left-wing
radical racists and perverts who are
trying to indoctrinate our youth and
we're going to get there Marxist hands
off of our children
we're going to defeat the cult of gender
ideology and reaffirm that God created
two genders called men and women
can feel bristling to my side here don't
join us by a polar and Adrian he's also
bristling we should tie us out of that
probably nodding away also we'll be now
is LGBT Rights Campaign and the Fox News
contributor Tommy later will welcome a
stellar panel I gotta say for this uh
all right uh Tommy later let me start
with you because it's been a big burning
issue in America now raging away for
quite some time it's one of the reasons
I think that Ron DeSantis the governor
of Florida has seen such surging
popularity potentially heading him to
the White House in this battle over what
you can teach at school with young
people in relation to this kind of thing
what is your view
listen we do not need to be teaching
this radical LGBT grooming agenda in
schools it's one thing if parents want
to do that on their own time that is a
parent's right to do that with some
exceptions of course but to bring this
in and bake this into a public school
curriculum is wrong and meanwhile
Chinese students are learning quantum
physics and we've got our students
learning how to twerk from drag queens
it's not going to end well this is
grooming this is ideological mind
control it's introducing this to a group
of individuals especially to young kids
who have no business learning any of
this sexually explicit material this is
not about being anti-gay or as the
incorrectly labeled Rhonda Sanders's
Bill don't say gay this is about keeping
this out of the classroom because it
does not belong there this is a grooming
agenda it is Extreme it is explicit it
does not belong in front of young
children at their school they should be
learning reading writing and arithmetic
not this filth well I think you've made
your position quite clear there Miss
Lauren I I imagine be detachable you
agree with every word of that
well here in Britain we know from
research that nearly half of all lesbian
gay bisexual and transgender pupils in
our schools have been bullied
bullied teased some sometimes subjected
to physical violence
simply because of their sexuality or
their gender identity so this education
of British schools is designed to combat
bullying and to promote understanding
and acceptance none of the teaching in
British schools is sexually explicit nor
is any of the material in United States
schools is all about promoting
understanding and tolerance so what's
just been said is a complete
misrepresentation of the teaching and I
think that any parent would want their
child to be brought up in a school where
understanding acceptance of difference
is valued where people are not bullied
because of their sexuality okay
I don't disagree with some of what you
just said I think the issue here is age
I've had I've got four kids you've all
gone through obviously all this I just
think the idea that at four any child
should be exposed to anything like this
is ridiculous I really do they're just
nowhere near old enough to to understand
or even begin to understand any of the
stuff that this is being taught in this
way so although this woman in this court
case did this on religious grounds
um she's a Catholic and this is what her
you know she believes her religion has
taught to believe that's one debate but
actually The Wider debate for me is what
age should we be teaching kids about
things like gender identity and should
they be compelled to go on Pride parades
and so on at the age of four I don't
think so
no one is compelling any child to go
into Pride Parade anywhere not in school
not in the street nowhere and when it
comes to teaching the teaching is not
about sex at a young age it's about
relationships and the fact that some
kids will be in married heterosexual
families some will be in single families
some will be in extended families and
some will be in same-sex families it's
all about different families that kids
in our schools are part of and of course
all those kids should feel loved and
appreciated the essence of this teaching
is about love and respect for other
people it's not it's not about sex at
all okay let's bring in the panel here
Paula good evening
I completely agree with Peter and I'm
really concerned that a commentator
could use the words radical and grooming
when we're having a very sensible
conversation about helping children to
understand who they are what as we saw
that Paula 78 of Americans would share a
lot of the views that Tommy Lauren
expressed there they do not want to see
kids age four getting bombarded with
this kind of ideology at school but what
kind of ideology what exactly are we
talking about and if you listen to Peter
I'll give an example when you start
teaching kids I mean the BBC for example
had a one of their teaching videos so
there were over a hundred genders the
BBC should not be teaching children
there are a hundred genders one of them
was Astra gender which is an affinity
with the Stars right the ones flying
around the moon so I'm sorry I do
actually think the children should not
be exposed to that kind of classes
who are desperately concerned about what
is being taught in primary school and
the truth is we don't know what's been
told about the high percentage of
children who suffer bullying who are
vulnerable
empathy that's got nothing to do with
gender ideology we don't need to take a
pride parade that's what this is about
it's not about being proud to be gay
tolerance and understanding but not at
four five six seven
aside from all of this we actually teach
sex quite explicitly in heterosexual
relationships from a really young age
you actually have children in Nativity
plays where you're playing a mother who
has an Immaculate Conception and then
gives birth to a baby what are you
teaching about stuff as I have done four
times had kids you've appeared in these
things they thought they haven't got a
Scooby-Doo or anything well I grew up
what's the purpose of that story the
purpose of that story is love yes the
purpose of that story is bringing people
together
well I want to bring it I want to bring
back Tommy Lauren here because we've had
a really scandalous case in the last few
days Tommy here in the UK of a
transgender person uh who committed two
rapes when identifying as a man rapes of
women and before the the court case
started it had transitioned to become a
woman and then was tried under a female
name and then when he's convicted this
person I'm using that term deliberately
I think because I I'm unconvinced by
this transition process when this person
was then convicted this
brought in a law which allowed this
trans person to then be put into a
woman's prison
as a woman who had literally got a penis
and raped two women so that not only
were they being punished by being put
into a place where they could attack
other women but they were being treated
as if they were legitimately exactly of
the same as a woman born to a female
biological body what do you make of that
but peers you're wrong you're wrong yeah
this is a problem that we are
encountering okay
all right well hang on let's go to Peter
first tripped me on what I said that was
wrong she was put in
she was put into a woman's prison but in
a segregation unit where she had no
contact with other women but she
shouldn't have been put in there at all
a rapist must never
a raper should never have contact or be
a potential risk to Other Woman She's
now been moved to a male prison quite
rightly and again she will have no
contact with women
say she has been moved to a male prison
quite rightly though because that
immediately to me sounds incredibly
confusing you're saying she so you
presumably think that she is a woman and
yet she is being moved to a male prison
because nobody else actually now thinks
she is actually a woman she's a man with
a penis who raped two women I mean
that's the reality even her ex well his
or her or purse whatever their ex-wife
said that this is all a complete scam to
game the system and get into a softer
prison
well I think you're probably right I
think it does look like the person is
gaming the system but you know the fact
is that the transfer to a woman's prison
was not based on any new law introduced
by the Scottish government it was based
on existing policy which was to respect
a person's gender identity but not under
any circumstances put someone who'd
committed crimes against women in
contact with other woman and that's why
she was in a segregation unit yeah look
I I don't think I what I said was wrong
because by new law I mean by new law I
meant this is a law that's come in in
recent years which allowed that gender
identity to be enforced in the way that
it was enforced and I Tommy Lauren I
just have a massive problem with people
this is what I've been saying from the
start about this trans debate the moment
the moment you open the door to this
kind of abuse by people it will happen
you know it's a bit like cheating in
sport once you allow it everyone starts
to cheat right you're going to get a
load of people who you know male rape
it's male sex offenders what's Utopia
for them if they get convicted being
taken from a Men's prison with their
pariahs and put into a woman's prison
surrounded by people they can attack
but they're over 200 yeah so I want to
be very clear about this not everybody
who is transgender does something like
this my turn to talk not everybody who
is transgender is going to do something
like this but you're opening the door
for this and even beyond that when we're
not even talking about a women's or a
Men's prison let's just talk about here
in the USA and I know in the UK as well
when they're having biological men
compete in women's sports using the same
locker rooms exposing themselves to the
female athletes that are often in high
school it's inappropriate it doesn't
belong in schools it doesn't belong in
society this free-for-all you can
identify as anything you can abuse the
system you can abuse this whole notion
of gender identity it's gone too far and
to even criticize it now has been
labeled bigotry it's not it's reality
okay to protect people we need to
especially protect young people well I I
actually agree with all that paid
attention I mean I've been watching some
interviews you've been doing I do think
you've been you know on a mission of
Discovery yourself about the perils here
of this particularly in this case in
Scotland of this rapist but if I was to
ask you now a question which has become
the most dangerous controversial
question in the world for some reason
you know what he's a woman to you
a trans woman is a woman but not the
same as biological women there's a
difference between biological sex and
gender identity both are equally valid
both equally deserve respect and equal
rights there should not be a competition
between biological women and trans women
they both suffer from very elevated
levels of domestic violence sexual
assault including rape that applies to
both trans women and other women as well
so let's find the common ground rather
than fighting each other the enemy is
misogyny that's the enemy not trans
woman well I think the enemy is misogyny
in many ways but I think the enemy is
also virtue signaling because the idea
that you can let trans women who have
massively Superior physical bodies
compete in professional sport against
women born to female inferior physical
bodies I think is for the birds but we
we will actually that's an unfortunate
Turner phrase I have no offense to
anyone who's offended by my use of the
word Birds
um but thank you very much Peter
tactical great to have you on the
program thank you Tommy layering great
to see you uh you're Pat you're staying
with me because after the break we're
going to talk about Burberry going
massively what I'll talk to
neuroscientist accuse them of
glamorizing breast removal
[Music]
foreign
ideology features gender neutral models
one of whom appears to be a
post-operative trans man bearing scars
on their chest from a double mastectomy
well my Pack's still with me and I'm
joined by Dr Deborah so is a
neuroscientist the best-selling author
at the end of gender well welcome to you
Dr so your thoughts on Miss Burberry
campaign
well hi Pierce thank you so much for
having me well with this campaign I have
to say we can't really say what
burberry's intentions were but I am very
concerned about this larger trend of
non-binary or of young women getting
double mastectomies presumably not for
health conditions but rather for an
aesthetic or because they like to live
as a gender that is in between male or
female or neither male or female there's
no such thing as being non-binary or
gender neutral there are two genders two
Sexes I discuss the science of this in
my book the end of gender as you
mentioned and I am very concerned
because in many cases these young women
have other psychological issues they
have a history of sexual trauma in some
cases they are on the autism spectrum
they are lesbian and not comfortable
with their sexuality or in some cases
they've gone through puberty and they're
just not fully comfortable in their new
more womanly body which is completely
normal and I would say every single
woman on this planet has had that
experience of being uncomfortable in her
body at some point in time especially
considering society and the way that
Society tends to sexualize women
especially post-puberty these are all
things that we should be talking about
especially for young women we should be
giving them that support they should be
getting a proper psychological
assessment before they are deciding on
surgery and so I can't believe that we
are now saying that as a society yes
young women if you are at all
uncomfortable in your bodies go ahead
and and cut off healthy tissue right I
mean look it's a it's a powerful
statement about this I just don't know
Richard what are Burberry doing getting
into any of this anyway it just seems to
me the ultra extreme end of The Virtue
signaling woke world where who's this
appealing to is a tiny tiny number of
people I don't know just looks it's
fashion company aren't they yeah and and
I just thought the picture was awful
horrible what's the what's the appeal I
don't think you're the audience I'm not
being rude
yeah I think it I think it's a beautiful
piece of art actually and I think it's
high culture and I think it's fashion I
think it's exciting it's pushing
boundaries actually
I think I think wow there's a split in
the world we do well for a start it's
not woke this is nothing to do with me
it all comes down there's nothing about
being awakened to an issue this is about
fashion but when I was younger we used
to just basically sell clothes and they
used on size two regular ways
who look like they was I don't agree
with that either on you know on drugs or
whatever it is alcoholics we are looking
at the Fashion industry as if they are
some kind of moral code yeah they are
not they never have been they never will
be this is about Burberry attempting to
be a little bit controversial to get us
all talking and then really what they're
doing is they're making more people
places very dangerous situations I'm
going to avoid the Temptation go to our
fashion expert Richards
final word to to Deborah we've just got
a few a few seconds left but you'll find
a word after hearing a little debate
there
well when you look at the scientific
research at the moment in terms of how
clinicians are being advised it really
is uh what the patient wants so the
patient wants to take a bit of hormone
here a little bit there remove this body
part add this body part in order to live
by this so-called non-binary aesthetic
that is exactly what they should advise
and also from a scientific perspective
de-transition tends to stop in four
years post-transition so we'll see what
happens to the end so run out of time
thank you I appreciate it if that's all
for them
[Music]
foreign